Something I absolutely love about homeschooling
is that we are taking a mental health day today.
And we can do that whenever mom or kids need it.
Because we've been traveling a lot.
We have been schlepping our kids around this goddamn country.
And not only am I tired,
they're tired,
they're exhausted,
they're cranky.
And because we're homeschooling,
we can literally be like,
you know what?
Not today. And before anyone comes at me in the comments,
this is not us being lazy.
That we are still getting all of our hundred eighty days of, like,
required log school hours in.
We actually started homeschooling in June,
so we are actually ahead of where we're supposed to be for the year.
So I'm sitting my ass in bed,
they're playing with the giant Legos I just got them.
And we are all gonna decompress.
Because if I hear one more argument between those children,
it's gonna drive me nuts.